you know you look at the dystopian um
dystopian worlds one of the elements of
it is everyone is frozen in their place
socialist countries communist countries
there are rich people
they're powerful people what you don't
see is new rich people what you don't
see
you know when my dad in 1957 was a
teenage
kid from cuba couldn't speak english
washing dishes making 50 cents an hour
why did he come to america because this
is a country where you could
be a teenage kid washing dishes and
climb
that socioeconomic ladder and it kind of
worked out for his kid
it if someone had told my father
in 1957 that 50 years in the future
his son would be in the senate that
teenage immigrant could never have
believed it and
and and that but if we can have
conversations then we can say all right
what works what doesn't work
the left is afraid to have those
conversations their ideas don't work
let's push a little further on so
because the left
wants to use state power in a way
that generally speaking the right
doesn't want to
or at least that you don't want to if
we're to go on this
dystopian future idea are you worried
that
if these guys really take power i mean
they're going to start jailing political
opponents
they are going to use we know they've
already used the irs to do all sorts of
crazy things
i mean these are things that are sort of
conspiracy theories and then suddenly
at this point nothing feels like a
conspiracy theory but
it it's all justified
in the in there's a self-righteousness
to it
we're right anyone who disagrees is evil
therefore anything is justified to
suppress the evil
you see that with cancer culture where
people go
like get driven out
out of the public discourse look when i
was
in college i was a college debater yes i
was one of the cool kids um
but so i was in college i was the
the chairman of the conservative group
in in the debate
debate society and and one of my closest
friends was the head of the liberal
group and we would have arguments about
free enterprise and socialism like what
works what actually
benefits humanity and actually that
question is an important question
too often people start with the
assumption the other side wants humanity
to suffer
if we start with the premise okay most
people of goodwill
would like people to be happier and more
well-off and more prosperous we start
with that premise
then we can have a conversation about
okay
what systems produce
more prosperity more opportunity it's
it's you know
a couple years ago i did three cnn town
hall debates with bernie sanders yep
and and they were 90 minutes long and
bernie look to bernie's credit he's an
unabashed socialist i disagree with him
but he's honest
and we can have a conversation about you
know socialism i think if you look
across the world
it doesn't work it's produced misery
poverty suffering
death you know my family fled cuba and
so i'm
more than happy to take the american
free enterprise system
or as the left derisively calls it
capitalism
and put it up next to communism or
socialism or any dictatorship they've
implemented in
every any country on earth and people
are better off they have more
opportunity and
in particular there's the mobility
you know you look at the dystopian
dystopian worlds one of the elements of
it is everyone is frozen in their place
socialist countries communist countries
there are rich people
they're powerful people what you don't
see is new rich people what you don't
see
you know when my dad in 1957 was a
teenage
kid from cuba couldn't speak english
washing dishes making 50 cents an hour
why did he come to america because this
is a country where you could
be a teenage kid washing dishes and
climb
that socioeconomic ladder and it kind of
worked out for his kid
it if someone had told my father
in 1957 that 50 years in the future
his son would be in the senate that
teenage immigrant could never have
believed it and
and that but if we can have
conversations then we can say all right
what works what doesn't work
the left is afraid to have those
conversations their ideas don't work
all right there there's a joke i i tell
sometimes which is
how many radical leftists does it take
to screw in a light bulb how many that's
not
funny like it's like guys just relax
like like like lighten up
and and you know my i was talking about
in college when when we were debating
we'd go
you know i he called me a fascist i'd
call him a
a a a communist then we could get a beer
like just you know not all of life has
to be
i must destroy my enemy and there's a
lot of that right now but do you think
there's a fundamental reason for that
i think there actually is that that
lefties
now and not always and i actually want
to ask you
about what it used to be like when there
was a sort of sane democratic party
but that there's a fundamental reason
for the the anger
and the outrage and the perpetual
craziness which is
they believe government is everything
and that you know this as a senator
it's a pretty freaking messy probably
often miserable game that you have to
play
to be to be a politician in america or
probably anywhere
and that because their whole world view
is through politics
as opposed to a religious or some other
spiritual world view well
of course you're going to be endlessly
miserable do you think i'm ball parking
something there
so i do and and it's
you know it was interesting i was
talking the other night
to a gentleman he and his wife came from
cuba and came from
cuba fled under under castro and he was
talking about he said
you know ted you talk about the
constitution quite a bit
and he said i think there are a lot of
people like me who who
came from countries the constitution was
meaningless
and they don't necessarily understand
why that matters and they're a little
bit
skeptical of what
why should the constitution make a
difference and i was
agreeing with him in that we need to
explain that more
government power the history of humanity
is largely in a history of government
oppressing the people
now you need some government not an
anarchist you need government
to to protect your your fundamental
rights
to life to liberty to property john
locke wrote wrote about the the
fundamental natural rights you need
government
to impose rule of law and you see
countries that don't have that
are disasters but the more power
government has
the less liberty you have and jefferson
had a great way of putting it he
described the constitution
as chains to bind the mischief of
government
um yeah that's pretty profound yeah you
know
free speech
is not about silencing those who
disagree with you
um religious liberty it's not about
forcing everyone to practice your faith
it's about saying look it's up to you
what faith you practice or none at all
that's that's
that right of conscience that you get to
decide that it's not
government that comes in you know you
just had
all right you know you talked about
abortion you and i may disagree on
abortion but you just had joe biden a
week ago
say if he's elected he's coming after
the little sisters of the poor
no i'm completely against that by the
way i mean i've done videos on it yeah
i mean that is an extreme view you
literally have politicians saying
those damn catholic nuns i'm going to go
after them
and force them to
pay for abortion-inducing drugs and
these are nuns who've taken vows of
poverty and helping
the poor and the sick and the needy and
and government now
for years has been persecuting them
because they must conform and it's just
look i think
being libertarian and living let live
giving people
like respecting diversity
solves a lot of the problems we have in
the country
so so speaking of diversity then do you
ever feel it because you mentioned
your father and your family's story
because you're a republican
because you're on the right that in many
ways the people who
love to scream about diversity all day
long they've sort of stolen that from
you
i know you don't wave it as a as a
victim card
but your own personal family story and
and because you're
you're you look white so to speak and
because you're on the right you're
you're
just a white guy congratulations
look i on social media
it is amazing you look at some of some
of the angry protesters
who who sometimes are
angry angry rich white guys
who are telling everyone look the riots
that that occurred
following the horrific killing of george
floyd
many of the neighborhoods that were
burned down were african-american
neighborhoods
some of the most poignant and powerful
videos
were of residents there crying going
okay you just burned my only grocery
store
you know my you know african-american
small business owners whose stores were
destroyed
and destroyed by
self-entitled often
middle or upper class kids if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell